[Music]
what's shaking team is your boy John
Humphrey je hum for short if we're in
high school again uh most people just
call me by my complete name anyway
welcome to another insight and welcome
to another exciting installment of TV
show reactions with me guess what guys
we're going back we're going back to one
of my personal favorites we're gonna
watch some Rick and Morty today going
kind of out of order with season three
here but I've done pickle Rick so far
than the Rick Lantis mix-up I'll
probably kind of hop around throughout
this season but today we're gonna watch
more teas mind blowers because I like a
good anthology which I assume this is
probably gonna be anyhow we can only
show about ten minutes of this reaction
here on the YouTube however if you want
to see the full thing uninhibited to
come on over to our patreon page we've
got a whole bunch of cool stuff over
there we got a really great community a
lot of cool people we do exclusive
reactions reviews viral videos stuff
music video stuff TV shows stuff like
this maybe even do some movie
commentaries and things like that so
come check us out over there if you
would be so kind also before we hop into
this wanna give a quick shout out to our
video sponsor and that is Stardust you
know their name the Stardust app allows
you to do 30-second reactions or reviews
to any movie TV show or trailer you can
go buy episode you can do it however you
like and we are on there we got a whole
bunch of reactions some of your favorite
youtubers are on there as well come on
over there check us out follow us first
if you would be so kind as well just so
they know that we sent you helps us out
huh
without further ado I've been screen
recording this whole time so that's
gonna be annoying to edit later but
whatever so right now I'm excited
the truth artist also really important
whatever you do dies
[Music]
come with me what he's gonna snap
[Music]
Gordan aloneness was a good marine we
don't know what drove him to take his
own life but we want to remember the
good things like how from a certain
angle some people would say he looked
like a smudge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
excuse me but I ordered the large ones
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh goodness gracious me Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're constantly fighting with each
other what
did it work did you guys get gobo home
you were supposed to bring it to the
hill stop that right there Todd stop
licking and Grill Morty's mind blowers
man I like to decided to do this instead
of interdimensional cable now that I
don't like interdimensional cable but
this is the craziest clip show episode
I've ever seen it is super meta also
like you said you're doing clip show a
bunch of clips we've never seen before
and then the clip show becomes a
catalyst for something to happen in the
main plot of the episode so I get I just
love they have an episode that's using a
clip show as a means for this weird
character development theoretically
speaking we did just learn a great deal
about Rick and Morty test out and it's a
little more written cuz interdimensional
cables very improv heavy you can tell
it's cool to get the variety but also I
think what they did with this you know
wound up being a really terrific episode
in and of itself even though it is kind
of a fun one for the season and I would
be curious to see how they might use it
again because the cool thing is you
could kind of do this whatever and as
long as the bits are fun you know it
works out and it just keeps that I guess
character development train rolling cuz
it forces you to think man after having
seen so much at a certain point you
probably might remove a memory from your
braid or something like that all these
things are true even the twist of the
egg because I started to think to myself
like oh god is that there's gotta be a
provision for all this I just love that
twist that summer walks in
like oh this is this is worse than I
thought okay
this being sort of business as usual for
her to the point that is just a chore I
thought that was really funny and the
fact that she liked reinstates their
right minds and then plops them down
into the conceit that they just fell
asleep during interdimensional cable
this is such a nice little button on
that to me and the sting at the end with
Jerry's mind blowers which you know of
course that's what would happen if Jerry
was put in charge of that scenario and
that just makes me wonder now going into
further seasons and whatnot are they
gonna do Jerry's mind blowers at some
point they're gonna do summers or Beth's
or you know anybody like the
possibilities are limitless so I thought
this was a really clever episode a
really fun episode a really dark episode
an episode that further expands this
messed up relationship that Rick and
Morty have in the family so yeah I
really dug this myth as a cool episode
of TV and I appreciate the amount of
weird metaphor thwa breaking 'no stood
there in to this stuff and it makes me
think too that maybe interdimensional TV
in the future might grow into something
you know beyond itself although I do
enjoy a good bit of interdimensional TV
and I like the weird improv based sort
of more freeform stuff but like the best
Rick and Morty episodes I feel like this
became so much tighter and so much more
crazy and multifaceted as it went along
and I really appreciate it for that so I
really enjoyed this episode for sure but
again I think they're doing cool stuff
with the forum as well as with the humor
and the storytelling the character
development and the edgy humor cuz they
get real dark with that humor is over
the time the whole thing with the moon
guy actually just being a smudge on his
telescope lens the squirrel reality is
horrifying
I think we're bestest blatently pics
summer or true left and the thing where
Morty's like coughing up the evil demon
worm is this is so gross and so cringy I
don't know anything that has to do with
like people plug in their minds into
stuff and like when I watch strange days
and the idea that you could like it
fried on playback or whatever that just
seems like such a not too far off and
creepy thing anything that like fries
your mind creeps me out like that so
like but he's just plugging in memory
after memory I'm like what is
you're it's the chemistry of your brain
kind of like that moment men in black
where he's freaking out about the
neuralyzer and they just like this
episode has a thing against men in black
to which I mean to be fair men have been
in black twos not great
save it for you too anyhow guys you can
see the full version of this reaction on
patreon as usual about ten minutes here
on the youtubes dia what did you guys
think of this episode hit us up in the
comment box would you like to see
another Morty's mind blowers or would
you rather go back to interdimensional
TV or or tales from The Citadel or
something like that next time I just
realize they're either they're like two
anthologies in this season so that's
cool I probably jump around into at
least a few more episodes from this
season maybe look into some other
animated shows as well but until then
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and get
notified every time a review or a video
is out download link in the description
box for the Stardust app come follow us
first over there and as always guys stay
sexy so six and I'll see you on the next
one peeps
choo-choo-choo Cheers